Farmar la cena comma got a is pruning
trees and killing weeds getting ready
for the next harvest the father of seven
children is convinced that his cashew
trees will bear far more nuts this year
than they have in the past you know that
choreographer Isis are constantly going
up they doubled over the course of last
season alone of course that's a lot of
good business and all the families here
are profiting from it come on not even
sauce or tea if you could love a missus
on gaming video , got a founded a co-op
with other farmers in the village
obtaining boo a in the heart of the
country today the chief buyer from the
olam company is visiting Holum is the
main cashew exporter in Ivory Coast
there will be more competition every
year I mean because the business is
showing I mean good health when a
business is good you will have
competition that we are confident
because these farmers this is why we are
building more than a customer
relationship it is a partnership that
rebuilding the cashew nuts are processed
here in the town of baka ivory coast has
grown into one of the biggest cashew
producers in the world and despite the
massive unrest here following the 2010
elections the olam company invested
millions here and created 2,000 jobs a
lucrative investment
every day 90 tons of cashews are
processed in this factory alone three
years ago
it was only half of that amount and
cashiers are only one example of the
booming economy here in Ivory Coast the
economy has grown by as much as 10%
annually in recent years but critics say
the rewards of the boom are not being
fairly distributed ina hopped out of
Cabo food eater Gill it'll certainly be
a prime objective of the government to
make economic growth inclusive that
means ensuring that those in informal
risky occupations for the unemployed are
also given a share that's clearly not
been the case in the last three or four
years and that has endangered social
stability dilute Alex Avila Ted calf
added nobody back of the chinning boo a
co-op is worried about social stability
right now la cena comma Gotti and his
colleagues want to make more money so
they'll soon be ordering more trucks to
deliver their ever-growing crop